[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
premier rendez vous de la semaine où on
va évidemment commencer par parler des
gilet jaune après la manifestation de
force d'hier ont-ils vraiment été
entendu par le gouvernement le premier
ministre affirme que oui mais on a le
droit d'avoir un autre avis et si c'est
le cas on l'écoutera avec beaucoup
d'intérêt on parlera aussi de la
souveraineté européenne
c'est l'un des points forts de la
politique étrangère des manuels macron
il l'a rappelé hier son discours auprès
du bundestag
soutenez-vous cette ambition
présidentielle de créer une souveraineté
européenne vous nous donnerez votre
point de vue et puis nous parlerons
aussi des déclarations fortes de laurent
wauquiez
c'était hier dans une journée organisée
par sens commun en parlant de la
procréation médicalement assistée
laurent wauquiez a employé le terme deux
génisses mme s approprier et bien on en
discutera et puis on parlera aussi
d'airbnb les députés français viennent
de voter de nouvelles sanctions contre
les propriétaires de logements qui ne
paierait pas les taxes qui s'applique
désormais à bienne be l'objectif est
clairement de 2,2 d'empêcher ce site de
trop se développer est-ce qu'il faut
effectivement barrer la route à airbnb
est ce que c'est une bonne idée est bien
là encore nous allons en discuter avec
nos quatre invités bonsoir caroline
valentin c'étaient les céistes
collaboratrice du figaro vox vous avez
contribué
vous êtes co auteur pardon du nouvel
antisémitisme ouvrage paru cette année
chez albin michel
voilà vous avez aussi contribuer à une
france soumise qui était un ouvrage
collectif dans le figaro magazine avait
longuement rendu compte lors de sa
parution
olivier babeau il a aussi bon soir soit
vous êtes économiste président fondateur
de l'institut sapiens qui est un think
tank de sensibilité libérale et vous
êtes l'auteur d'un éloge de l'hypocrisie
ce titre m'enchante déjà de france soir
voilà et ça a été publié aux éditions du
cerf frédéric dabi et là aussi bon soit
frédéric sarre politologue et directeur
général adjoint de l'institut ifop
et puis notre quatrième invité et périco
légasse bonsoir journaliste critique
gastronomique ce soir président
de la soirée du prix taittinger qui
distingue chaque année à un grand chef
cuisinier c'est bien ça vous êtes le
rédacteur en chef de rubrique vin et
gastronomie de marianne est votre
dernier livre à table citoyens pour
échapper à la malbouffe et sauvé nos
paysans a été publié lui aussi aux
éditions non j'en ai et publia vous
n'avez pas encore parlé mais ce qui ne
serait d'ailleurs le figaro magazine qui
est du panier à l'assiette avec serge
papin ok le figaro a consacré deux pages
serge par la has absolument savoir
certains jours je sais pas ce qui s'est
passé pourquoi ça s'est bien couché
quelques jets de progresser femme il
avait deux bouts
c'est cela on rappelle que serge papin
c'est le patron du marché de gros christ
et le choc des conditions absolument
alors on commence donc par ce sujet qui
s'impose évidemment à nous aujourd'hui
celui des gilet jaune après la
démonstration de force d'hier
edouard philippe le premier ministre
était sur france 2 à 20 heures hier soir
peut-être l'avez-vous entendu sinon vous
allez pouvoir réécouter une partie de
son intervention
en gros pour lui c'est clair le patron a
donné le cap et on n'en bougera pas le
cap il est bon et nous allons le tenir
et c'est pas quand ça souffle qu'il faut
changer de cap donc la norme fixée par
le président si si le cap fixé par le
président nous allons le tenir
il ne faut l'objectif fixé au
gouvernement par le président la
république c'est de baisser les
prélèvements obligatoires les impôts et
taxes
c'est une revalo ces deux noms mais ça a
commencé cette année monsieur delahousse
c'est de revaloriser le travail entendez
bien qu'ils ne ressentent pas les frais
en tous cas les plus sévères fait rose
c'est un fait
c'est un fait et on peut sans doute à la
fois beaucoup mieux expliquer et
beaucoup mieux accompagner alors on va
débattre
bien sûr de cette réponse du premier
ministre pour savoir si elle est adaptée
mais avant j'aimerais vous faire écouter
un point de vue intéressant celui du
géographe christophe guilluy vous savez
c'est l'homme qui a théorisé la france
périphérique
il était ce matin sur europe 1 et pour
lui ce qu'on a vécu hier s conduit
d'ailleurs encore en partie aujourd'hui
pardon avant-hier mais aussi fière
aujourd'hui puisque ce mouvement se
prolonge s'est pas seulement une révolte
contre les taxes est aussi un épisode le
énième épisode du grand décrochage des
classes moyennes basses qui s'est passé
ce week-end c'est ce qui se passe depuis
10 20 30 ans c'est à dire un espèce de
délitement très très fort de ce qu'on
appelait hier la classe moyenne ou
plutôt de son socle
le solde de la classe moyenne ces
ouvriers s'est employé ces paysans ces
petits indépendants et quand on met bout
à bout toutes ces catégories
bah ça forme un tout quoi sa forme la
classe moyenne et c'est pour ça que je
disais toujours attention on ne parle
pas d'un phénomène conjoncturel
oui à l'augmentation du prix du gasoil
mais avant que ça mais bien sûr on est
sur du temps long du coup car une
valentin le bonnement peut pas faire
grand chose d'autre que de dire je tiens
mon cap parce que comme le disait guy
lui le problème est tellement vaste
qu'il n'y a pas une réponse comme ça
immédiate ou facile à un tel
gouvernement en fait devrait précisément
aborder ces questions parce qu'en fait
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en france
c'est ce qui se passe depuis très
longtemps dans plein de pays occidentaux
ou qu'est ce qui s'est passé les
mouvements qu'on a appelée populistes
ont augmenté ont gagné des points
beaucoup de points dans les sondages et
in fine et soit ça me déçoit à des
mouvements populistes qui avait le
pouvoir comme en italie ou trump aux
états unis soit à des coalitions
gouvernementales avec ces mouvements
populistes soit quant à caen peut
arriver à les freiner
quand les partis dits républicains en
fait les parties du milieu se sont enfin
décidés à aborder les préoccupations de
cet électorat
donc voilà ce qu'on leur demande juste
en fait c'est pour une fois enfin
d'aborder les préoccupations cet
électorat vous savez christophe buisson
est pris plein la figure depuis le temps
qu'il est créé sur la france
périphérique
il s'est fait traiter de tous les noms
il avait écrit un je me rappelle enfin
j'aime tout le monde a dû entendre
parler de ça lui et quelques autres
auteurs dont laurent bouvet un livre sur
à l'attention du candidat françois
hollande à l'époque l'incitant justement
à avoir une politique de gauche pour le
peuple en bas françois hollande l'a pas
écouté sarkozy l'avait un peu plus
écoutées en disant à travailler plus
pour gagner plus il a gagné au passage
et depuis plus personne ne les écoute
voilà donc un jour ça sera la fraude
on rappellera que cette france
périphérique interdit par christophe
guilluy c'est celle qui ne profite pas
de la mondialisation c'est celle qui
n'habitent pas dans les métropoles c'est
à dire ni les classes favorisées ni les
classes sociales issues de l'immigration
qui elles sont globalement dans le dans
le circuit récollets gardons ce qui est
très intéressant d'ailleurs c'est que ce
que christophe de lui décrit ce sont des
gens qui se sont partis en fait de ces
banlieues près des grandes métropoles
pour éviter le conflit culturel avec des
populations qui de plus en plus n'ont
pas ne partage pas mais la même identité
culturelle cup
compte tenu de la grande immigration
parce qu ils viennent de l'immigration
musulmane pour dire les choses
des gaz toutes étaient cuits sociologue
qui examine les faits domaine
géographique sociaux graphique français
donc la classe dominante le pouvoir ne
peut pas ignorer tout tu as été dit ou
lui a été révélée il est confronté
aujourd'hui à une situation inédite
sociologiquement c'est la descente dans
la rue ça fait combien de temps qu'on me
dit ça va finir dans la rue ça ne venait
jamais je me souviens l'automne va être
chaud ça ne venait jamais là on a un
début de descente dans la rue de façon
concrète nationale alors on peut
chiffrer 200 300 400 milles on ne sait
pas comment ça va finir
ce que je voudrais comprendre c'est en
quoi la prise de la bastille n'était pas
populiste
en quoi la commune de paris n'était pas
populiste le problème c'est que c'est
populaire si c'était que populiste c'est
à dire un espèce de poujadisme contrôler
ou récupérés par j'allais dire des
moyens peu subversif pour créer un
désordre c'est populaire c'est une
partie du peuple français ce sont des
électeurs sur des gens qui paient des
impôts qui sont actifs
c'est pas que des chômeurs c'est des
gens qui travaillent voilà et là nous
sommes confrontés à une fracture sociale
celle de 95 dans chirac nous avait dit
le 26 octobre 95 ha je peux pas tenir ma
première ses lectures al séguin les
faits sont programmés fracture sociale
jeu
pour revenir à une politique monétaire
donc ça fait 40 ans qu'on explique aux
français nous n'appliquerons pas ce
pourquoi vous nous elysées et à chaque
fois qu'ils battent que ce soit chirac
de ce soit sarkozy que ce soit aux
lentes et on va changer les précédents
étaient des nuls nous nous avons tout
compris et celui là est arrivé en disant
je fous quarante années de politiques en
l'air avec moi vous allez voir ce qui va
se passer je vais remettre la france au
travail je vais réparer je vais venir
vers vous
la situation n'a jamais été aussi
catastrophique nous avons jamais eu à
président de la république aussi peu de
tenir deux promesses et aussi fauteurs
de trouble que celui là il ya de quoi
être inquiet alors on va continuer ce
tour de table mais je vais vous donner
le point de vue aussi deux de nos
internautes que pour pouvoir nourrir le
vôtre gazelle 83 nous dit très content
de voir ses syndicats politisés éjecté
de ce mouvement populaire une réaction
de marine on ne connaît pas son nom de
famille il faut que les gens comprennent
que l'on ne peut pas toujours payer plus
de taxes et d'impôts par rapport à nos
voisins européens anti mac qui trouvent
que ce qui est étonnant dans ce
mouvement
c'est de voir leur amateurisme mais
aussi leur détermination et christophe
new deal et gilet jaune ne seront pas
entendus car le gouvernement mise sur un
épuisement du mouvement la plupart sont
des salariés alors à ce stade du débat
en fait il ya deux sujets il ya la
question qu'on se pose le départ c'est à
dire est-ce que et sont vraiment entendu
et puis eux
est-ce que j'étais vraiment cette france
là qui étaient dans la rue et là
évidemment je me tourne vers le vert le
sondeur cette france que décrit périco
légasse et terre celle qui est depuis
depuis 20 ans à l'écart des promesses
des politiques hors oui non car compte
tenu de ce mouvement de 7 ce que j'ai
appelé un os ni un objet social non
identifié qui n'est pas comme vous
disiez canalisée par un mouvement
syndical quand vous dites on attendait
dans la rue justement c'est parce que
les syndicats qui n'ont pas remporté une
victoire depuis le cpe en 2006 n'ont pas
réussi dans ce contexte
d'affaiblissement des corps
intermédiaires qui touche aussi les
partis politiques à canaliser la colère
là où il ya une vraie différence par
rapport au quinquennat précédent
c'est qu'il ya une véritable
insatisfaction à l'égard du gouvernement
et du président mais il n'y a pas deux
il n'y a pas de réceptacle n'y a pas de
débouchés à la colère d'où l'émergence
de ce mouvement spontané ou pas mais en
tout cas derrière ce mouvement
faut voir son moteur si je puis dire
sans aucune sans aucun jeu de mots c'est
le pouvoir d'achat dans les raisons du
mécontentement de ce week-end
david emmanuel macron il perd encore
quatre points dans le baromètre jdd il
est seulement un point au dessus de son
socle électoral
23/08/2010 est les sujets sont écrasés
par le pouvoir d'achat ils sont
révélateurs
la hausse du prix du carburant donc il
faut pas je dirais que la question c'est
parce qu'à men macron doit entendre les
gilet jaune
il n'ya pas d'incarnation de ce
mouvement il ya il est relativement
atomisé mais elle comment va-t-il faire
pour obtenir des résultats auprès de
l'ensemble des français sur la question
du pouvoir d'achat
le quinquennat de françois hollande
c'était avait fini par tourner autour
d'une bataille qui est va-t-il réussir à
inverser la courbe du chômage on a vu ce
qui s'est passé est même pas pu se
représenter
le quinquennat est en train de tourner
devan macron est en train de tourner
autour de la question
va-t-il améliorer le pouvoir d'achat les
français et donc réduire ses fractures
sociales un tout petit mot les classes
moyennes on est complètement là dedans
dans les sujets de récriminations des
français émerge la protestation la voice
des classes moyennes parce que c'était
le livre de valéry giscard d'estaing
tout le monde se définit comme casse
moyenne deux français sur trois est donc
ont ils se sentent trop aisé pour
pouvoir bénéficier des aides pas assez
aisé pas assez riche pour pouvoir
bénéfique pour le pouvoir par exemple et
de ces logiques d'exemption d'impôts
d'optimisation qu'ils se sentent dans un
contexte ils savent très bien que 56 %
des foyers français ne sont pas
imposables au titre de l'impôt sur le
revenu ils se sentent complètement elle
pourrait être notre vie meilleure mais
là vous pourrez ce que le gouvernement
pourrait pas répondre concrètement à
cette demande si le pouvoir d'achat en
par exemple en reportant la hausse des
taxes sur le gasoil en disant on fera ça
quand les prix du pétrole baissent rond
on al'impression la queue à la fois le
premier ministre dit qu'il entend la
colère la souffrance le sentiment
d'abandon ce sont ses mots à dire soir
mais qu' il veut pas bouger
c'est pas un peu une impasse dans
laquelle il se met lui même d'un point
de vue économique c'est extrêmement
difficile d'évaluer politique d'abord
c'est très difficile de reculer après ce
mouvement ce serait effectivement après
une communication terrible et d'un point
de vue économique et de transition
énergétique
ça correspond cette augmentation du prix
du duc de l'essence à des engagements
assez clair qu'ils ont été tenues très
difficile de revenir en depuis longtemps
va y aura et depuis
depuis 2015 en réalité en fait les
engagements avaient été pris et en fait
on voit bien que le modèle macro
aujourd'hui paye pour un délitement un
décrochage qui effectivement bien
antérieurs à son élection qu est ce qu
on a vu dimanche on a vu d'abord pour
moi c'était l'aube sec 20 les obsèques
des corps intermédiaires
je veux dire en grande pompe on a eu les
obstacles des corps intermédiaires qui
n'ont plus aucune place aucun rôle à
jouer
du coup on a plus de tampon par équipes
est donc absolument et et la deuxième
chose évidemment que c'est une sorte de
cri d'alarmé des des classes pour dire
des classes intermédiaires des classes
pourrait dire effectivement des classes
moyennes qui sont en voie de disparition
qui se voit décroché depuis 30 ans à qui
la mondialisation n'a en fait rien
apporté d'autre qu en réalité une
augmentation des dépenses contraintes et
de plus en plus finalement l'impression
qu'on a eu moins de pouvoir d'achat dont
on sait bien que l'insee montre que
paradoxalement on en a pas tellement
moins mais que c'est surtout une
impression que c'est psychologique parce
qu'en effet les dépenses contraintes
elles ou augmenter en particulier pour
certaines personnes on se rend bien
compte que beaucoup de gens ont
l'impression d'être trop riche pour être
pauvre et en avoir les avantages et les
aides évidemment trop pauvre pour être
riche c'est à dire en avoir la capacité
d'action c'est ces gens là qui
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on a vu dans les
images et les gens qui paraît de toute
évidence c'est la france effectivement
traditionnel la france pourrait dire on
pourrait dire des petits blancs parce
que populaire parce qu'on voyait très
peu de minorités ethniques etc les gens
qui ont compris que la politique n'était
plus fait pour car la politique
hier était présent en fait pour la
normalité pour la norme au sens le
milieu aujourd'hui ce sont des
politiques qui sont faites pour les
marges car oui et je crois que ce qui
est intéressant de dire de noter aussi
c'est que ce mouvement était déclenchée
par cette décision sur l'augmentation du
prix de l'essence et sur la réponse qu'a
fait dans un premier temps l'exécutif
aux français qu'il disait mais on n'a
pas l'argent mais c'est pas grave
achetez donc une voiture électrique et
en leur disant je sais que c'est assez
cher mais on va vous en payer 4000 euros
mais les gens aux commandes
vous savez les gens changent de produits
n'achète eu un produit quand ils
augmentent de 5 centimes
ils n'ont plus d'argent c'est ce que
christophe guilluy dix ans mais si vous
savez une grande partie du temps de
beaucoup de français et est utilisé à
kicker
j'ai mensuel pour ne pas sortir des
clous ont pensé qu'ils ont l'argent pour
acheter des milliers de sites
reconnaissent que cette aide elle va
aussi pour des voitures d'occasion
classique mais qui compte même si a dès
lors qu'elles consomment moins c'est la
phrase que d'ailleurs la reine elle pas
prononcé je ne connais pas couvrir ce
qui est honteux dans cette histoire
c'est que ce gouvernement qui soit
disant défend l'écologie
quel pire service rendent à l'écologie
que redire à ces gens mais c'est pour
des mesures écologiques
on vous taxe un petit peu plus votre
essence qui est vital pour vos
déplacements
mais c'est pour le bien de la planète
donc vous êtes des affreux et des
méchants parce que vous refusez cet
effort on dirait vraiment que ce
gouvernement des tests d'écologie est ce
qui explique un peu le départ de m ni ni
de nicolas hulot on achève nicolas hulot
en disant c'est pour l'écologie c'est
pour la sauvegarde de la planète
quand le premier ministre qui utilisent
mal la langue française dit avec mépris
les seigneurs disais oh que je vous
entends du jeu l'entrée non je vous ai
écouté je ne suis pas toujours obligé
d'aller dans le sens de ce que vous
suggérez
je vous ai écoutés serge est pris en
considération propos je vous ai entendu
macron avait dit je entendu pour ne pas
dire je m'excuse j'ai entendu les
remarques qu'on a fait sur le mes
différentes petites sorties qui s'y
était très maladroite et là je les ai
entendu autrement dit je m'en fous nous
nous continuerons comme ça nous avons la
légitimité du suffrage universel pour
cinq ans et là la vérité ne se passera
pas dans la rue sauf que là ils ont à
faire est de catégorie de gens qui sont
des électeurs je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord je crois qu'il ya des électeurs
du front national et la france 2007 il
ya encore et le climat d'une manière
générale mais quand on regarde le
soutien à ce
mouvement social c'est une enquête pour
ses pour ses news
on voit que le soutien et le plus fort
auprès des électeurs la france insoumise
et des électeurs du rassemblement
national
un tout petit élément très simple
n'avons posé une question qui est vous
sentez-vous dépendant de votre voiture
dans votre vie quotidienne
69 des fins d % des français disent oui
donc on est loin de la voiture
électrique et de la multi modalité ça
monte à 90 % dans les communes rurales
et comme par hasard ce sont près des
électeurs du rassemblement national peut
être ces petits blancs ou le sentiment
de dépendance et donc de budget
contraint est le plus fort et ce que je
vois là c'est un début d'union nationale
et c'est comme ça comment jeter
révolution nous en sommes loin je ne
suis pas autant l'extrapoler mais c'est
un prémisse est une semence mais c'est
surtout des gens qui ne votait pas
qu'ils n'ont pas voté en 2010 est donc
en fait il se double maintenant qu'il
appelle vous avez vu la rue par une
majorité de français c'est le système le
lannic par le groupe reed abstention
forte lors la peine le groupe
parlementaire république en marche avec
3 158 députés fille 14 87 % des inscrits
c'est un problème il est totalement
légale et légitime
c'est quand même au sein de cette unité
sur wii la gsma dans l'essonne avec une
circonscription très politisé à cause de
diana 14% 14%
mais ça veut dire les peuples français
ne fait plus confiance dans les missions
relatives partiel on rappelera à la
suite de la démission de manuel valls ou
et plus de 80% d'abstention draps dans
une circonscription politisé il y avait
un enjeu local une vraie campagne
effectivement quelques commentaires de
nos internautes
monsieur babineau qui estiment que le
gouvernement est dans une logique de
confrontation élan qui dit les 80
kilomètres heure ont été le déclencheur
sur la méthode autoritaire du
gouvernement je suis assez d'accord avec
ça et r34 le gouvernement entend mais ne
cède pas la réponse efficace sera le
vote en mai prochain
vous pensez frédéric effectivement un
mouvement comme celui-là peut contribuer
à structurer le vote pour les
européennes en tout cas quand on voit le
rapport de force électoral on observe
une véritable un véritable effondrement
d'un atomique en marche qui étaient
autour de 28 30 % avant les vacances
côte maintenant autour de 18 1 % +10
points il a perdu 10 points une enquête
a été publiée par quantic ou encore ce
week end ce qui est assez notable
dans l'essonne était soutenu par oui non
mais bien sûr vous avez raison mais sur
les élections européennes ce qui est
aussi notable et ça fait nous dit aussi
avec cette ce mécontentement des petits
sur la question du poids d'achat c'est
que ça fait maintenant trois enquêtes
que le rassemblement national pour
disaient en si grande difficulté après
la catastrophe présidence il ya des
marine le pen arrive en tête quand on
voit les sujets qui sont au coeur de
l'agenda politico médiatique et des
français insécurité question des
migrants et puis cette question de la
vie chère on retrouve une marine le pen
qui se fait la porte-parole des petits
quand on regarde les seules forces
dynamiques
aujourd'hui nicolas dupont aignan et le
rassemblement national juste un mot
là-dessus marine le pen et jean-luc
peine en france on serait tu au lieu
d'essayer faire la reid qui la
récupération de bas étage le chiffre
démobilisés ont répété qu'ils doublent
il ya des gens qui parce qu'ils refusent
des corps intermédiaires anani on va pas
leur servir la soupe mais moi j'ai connu
des gens qui m'ont dit j'étais prêt à y
aller mais puisque mère marié mélenchon
dans le cul perret gas toho moi je
n'irai pas peut-être qu'on va continuer
à parler de ce sujet près tout ce
mouvement n'est pas fini on va le savoir
dans les jours qui viennent
regardez en tout cas ce qui est
l'opinion des internautes du figaro
puisque c'est la question du jour
sur le figaro.fr les gilets jaunes
doivent-ils poursuivre leur mobilisation
ce n'est pas un sondage on rappelle à
nouveau mais sur les trente-six mille
votants
il ya une majorité mais assez faible qui
considère que oui dans l'école et figaro
vient débattre ce sont les lecteurs du
figaro dire que 76 % de la population
d'être un as tu les appellations
sauf que vous savez que voilà les
internautes du figaro ils sont plus de
20 millions de visiteurs uniques par
mois donc ça ça fait du monde
on parlait du pression d'un public
continuons à le faire si vous le voulez
bien
emmanuel macron et et hier à berlin
devant le bundestag dans une visite qui
était prévu de longue date et il a
réaffirmé son credo que l'avenir de
l'europe c'est ce qu'il appelle une
souveraineté européenne certains disent
que c'est un oxymore parce que la
souveraineté c'est forcément celle des
pays mais pour emmanuel macron c'est ça
ou le chaos il n'y a pas d'alternative
regardez l'europe et en son sein le
couple franco-allemand se trouve investi
de cette obligation de ne pas laisser le
monde glisser dans le chaos et de
l'accompagner sur le chemin de la paix
c'est pour cela que l'europe doit être
plus forte
c'est pour cela qu'elle doit être plus
souveraine alors ce concept d'europe
souveraine est intéressant parce que
traditionnellement on considère que la
souveraineté c'est-à-dire la la faculté
de décider de ce que doit être son
avenir c'est l'apanage des nations
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce 2 7 de
cette volonté d' emmanuel macron de
partager la souveraineté par exemple
avec l'allemagne et plus largement avec
l'europe
olivier babeau c'est évidemment la
question fondamentale je crois que
souvent en communication jusque-là
macron a fait l'erreur d'opposer on
pourrait dire les méchants souverainiste
forcément destructeur et balkany thater
on pourrait dire de l'europe et puis les
gentils fédéraliste en quelque sorte
avec une vision un peu trop binaire soit
vous êtes pour une europe très très
forte soit vous êtes contre est ce
moment là vous êtes des êtres des
méchants d'un point de vue géopolitique
il faut quand même bien dire aujourd'hui
qu'il faut que les gens comprennent que
les pays tout seul même la france avec
ses 60 millions d'habitants aussi
brillant soit-il n'a aucune chance
aucune arrivée à tenir sa place dans le
monde face à la plaque asiatiques en
particulier si on n'est pas unie au
niveau européen donc la nécessité
d'avoir peut-être une armée européenne
avec effectivement une part d' abandon
de souveraineté dont il faut débattre
qui est une réalité mais qui pourrait
avoir une utilité
et puis des capacités a décidé un budget
européen propre et puis une capacité à
enfin avoir ce fameux numéro de
téléphone européen pour qu'on pèse au
niveau mondial
c'est la chance pour l'europe de
continuer à offrir à ses
ressortissants une prospérité à l'avenir
malheureusement je crois que de ce point
de vue la zale with no other way
collectif oublier la souveraineté
française où il faut là le passé plutôt
en totalité cordialité la la cabriole
intellectuelle que vous venez de faire
pour nous expliquer que l'europe est
dans une situation d'échec total
et quand on est au point de préciser la
souveraineté européenne ça devrait être
quelque chose d'acquis et d'actes et
donc il n'ya bien pas de souveraineté
européenne moi qui me fais techt et des
souverainistes justement parce que je
dis que je veux une autre europe
je ne supportais européens d'abord ce
continent et que j'allais dire
indissoluble
c'est cette union européenne qui ne
fonctionne pas dans le sens que nous
voulons et les gilet jaune ne sont
qu'une forme d'expression de ce rejet de
ce système néolibéral fille nancy qui
nous ruine qui n'enrichit que les riches
et finalement réuni classe moyenne
l'europe est assimilé à cet
appauvrissement parce que le système
économique
bruxelles la commission décide en fait
de la monnaie forte et pour quoi pour
plaire à l'économie allemande on est
tous à la traîne de l'économie allemande
c'est madame merkel qui dirige l'europe
il faut une souveraineté mais bien sûr
qu'il faut une souveraineté européenne
avec une avec un osons le mot un
protectionnisme par franco
franchouillard un protectionnisme
européen
lien un marché commun avec la fameuse
formule de la préférence communautaire
une armée européenne mais il faut une
armée européenne faisait trop massif où
les états unis d'europe je suis ultra
européen mais une europe avec des
frontières et on dit à la chine et aux
pays émergents
nous ne prendrons vos produits que s'ils
ne détruisent pas nos emplois préférence
communautaire on se sert d'abord à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne et si
nous n'avons pas la marchandise à ce
tarif
à ce moment là nous pouvons aller voir
ailleurs mais n'at il ya un autre
problème c'est que nous sommes aussi 1,2
million économiques et militaires des
états unis et que monsieur q monsieur
train ne s'est pas trompé il a bien
compris quand vous voulez mais d'heure
alors lui ne veut plus être le gendarme
du monde
mais la souveraineté européenne elle
n'existe pas donc il faut la faire mais
on nous a fait croire jusqu'à présent
qui avait une souveraineté européenne et
que l'europe nous protégerait l'europe
ne nous protège de rien elle est en
train de créer le cercle le caveau la
tombe de la civilisation occidentale
vous pose la question sur twitter un
soutenez vous
ce projet de souveraineté européenne
portée par un manuel macron vous êtes
une majorité à quoi répondre
négativement presque deux tiers à cette
question et puis quelques commentaires
d'internautes
watch out qui nous dit il faut une
europe des nations l'europe d'erasmus du
spatial l'europe du général de gaulle
anti mac nous dit le discours de macron
à berlin est hors sol qui va diriger
cette armée européenne
contre qui quelle sera la politique de
cette armée c'est vrai car une valentin
que on comprend le concept de
souveraineté européenne mais ensuite
concrètement quand on arrive à dire qui
a qui vont être les patrons qui va
répondre au téléphone d'ailleurs de ce
fameux numéro où on pourrait appeler
l'europe
écoutez oui enfin ce qui est très
surprenant en fait c'est que encore une
fois un peu comme avec la voiture vous
savez on veut que les gens achètent une
voiture électrique sauf que la voiture
électrique ça marche pas bien
une fois de plus cela on veut mettre la
charrue avant les boeufs tous les pays
européens où à peu près tous les peuples
des pays européens crient qu'ils ne
veulent plus d'europe parce qu'ils ne
savent pas ce qu'est l'europe parce que
ce qu'est l'europe aujourd'hui et en
veut le plus souvent non plus parce que
l'europe ils veulent pas cette europe là
et avant de savoir si on veut plus
d'europe peut-être définir quelle europe
il s'agit et là vraiment quand on fait
une cantonale dans l'idée de pareil
quand on parle de souveraineté de
souverain donc deux nations la première
chose de première question que l'on doit
aborder c'est celle de l'identité de
quelle est la culture quel type de
d'identité culturelle de l'europe fait
on savait que ce sujet a été évacuée en
2005 de maastricht il n'a pas voulu être
abordée et qu'aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui
se passe on a un problème prégnant entre
les pays anglo-saxons et leur modèle
multiculturaliste est le nôtre à nous
français qui est un modèle
intégrationniste mais qui est un modèle
qui a marché vous savez connaître les
premiers pays d'immigration en europe
puisque honda on a happé des immigrés
d'ennemis et du 10ème siècle à l'époque
qu'un autre pays européens et que des
immigrés donc nous on sait comment ça
marche et pour autant l'europe n'arrête
pas de donner des coups de boutoir des
coups sur la tête à notre modèle
intégrationniste pour qu'on accepte de
ne considérer plus les yeux et les idées
êtres humains en tant qu'individu avec
des droits des devoirs et tout mais les
communautés les religions et la
confrontation et la coexistence des
cultures ce que les gens ne veulent plus
et cette europe là et qu'est ce qui dit
macro est dit on va en faire plus mais
franchement je veux dire d'autant qu'en
plus ils pourraient quand même utiliser
son pouvoir effectivement l'europe ne
tient pas son le couple franco allemand
ben moi j'aimerais bien vous savez que
pour une fois un président européen
ça c'est un peu la politique de la
chaise vide dire écoutez vous avez
besoin de moi je vais vous expliquer ce
qu'on veut maintenant on veut arrêt on
veut plus que vous savez on a un
infiltration par le droit notre modèle
est attaqué par le doyen trop un article
de marie ne pouvait dans causeur de
surgélation exactement là le président
premier président de la cour de
cassation qui a expliqué qu' il fallait
se conformer à la décision à l'avis de
la cdc la première question qu'il faut
aborder avant de savoir si on veut plus
de souveraineté puisque les peuples vous
disent tous qu'ils n'en veulent plus je
sais pourquoi tu européenne quand tu en
sais moi je quand on écoute le discours
des français sur l'europe
il a quand même pas mal muté depuis ces
dernières années ce que vous dites est
complètement repris l'euroscepticisme la
critique / union européenne est
majoritaire on a voté il ya à peine 13
ans le 29 mai 2005 quand on repose cette
question du référendum pour le figaro il
ya à peine deux trois ans on est sur du
deux tiers un tiers à peu près votre
consultation pour autant et là je
rejoins ce qu'a dit olivier babeau les
français ont de plus en plus conscience
que les solutions sur les sujets des
solutions sur les sujets qui les
concernent le plus migrants terrorisme
réchauffement climatique doit se ne
peuvent se faire qu'à l'échelle
européenne dans le cadre est donc
l'attention et entre cette prise de
conscience que oui avec 60 millions de
français
on ne peut plus jouer le même rôle
qu'avant mais il voit l'impuissance et
l'incapacité de l'europe à trouver des
solutions mais il faut pas seulement
rester sur le discours eurosceptiques
alors ce qu'a proposé
emmanuel macron c'est une manière de
sortir de je dirais d'antagonisme entre
souveraineté nationale et fédéralisme
européen
mais ce ce concept de souveraineté
européenne il faut bien sûr l'incarner
c'est pour mon avis une sorte de
coquille quand on interroge les français
sur une armée européenne sur un budget
européen à avoir sur un président des
amis d'europe
ils sont très nettement majoritaire y
compris des électeurs nonistes panneaux
coopération souveraineté c'est quand
même un pas de plus je vois pas très
bien comment se faire une souveraineté
même un budget commun quand on a pas de
fiscalité commune quand on veut bien sûr
si c'est bon c'est le fonds euros et
d'autre c'est 1000 cc pour ça les
défections ont continué avec toutes les
ouvertures que d'autres criaient jamais
avant les boeufs 28 sites eu l'idée des
28 qui est philosophiquement formidable
actu et l'europe alors qu'à 12 et 16 on
serait arrivé bien plus vite et bien
plus loin parce que concrètement je sais
plus lequel l'auto vous le disais mais
d'un souverainisme ya sous vraiment
comment on fait pour choisir le
souverain de l'europe qui va être oui
c'est vous et c'est vous carole dans le
rock est ce qu'il faut voter croyez
qu'il faudrait voter à la la le suffrage
universel tous les européens pour élire
un président de rock dans le pays qui
évidemment le plus grand poids
démographique serait logiquement celui
qui a la plus grande capacité
vous auriez probablement après des
effets de discussion se fasse
normalement oui
puis en fonction des coalitions a
développé avec d'autres pays mais c'est
vrai ce qu'on a dit est tout à fait vrai
le problème de la deûle à l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est oui ça c'est la crème
hétérogénéité des pays entre entre les
pays de l'est et lé pays français je
crois qu'aujourd'hui le la complexité
c'est ce qu'on met d'ailleurs
souveraineté souveraineté européenne
mais c'est clair c'est que les gens
réclament des réclames des frontières et
y réclame après probablement un
leadership économique et de vision
économique et ça l'intégration
économique ces trucs qu'on amour et non
le retrait pour l'instant et de la
souveraineté démocratique pas en signant
des traités ou le peuple même ne l'ait
pas consultée le parlement quasiment
détourné et ce sont des fonctionnaires
dans les lui qui dans des bureaux obscur
signe des traités qui ne sont pas soumis
à la volonté d
une crise démographique pendant
démocratique regardez l'italie par
exemple et même peut-être aujourd'hui la
grande bretagne s'est pas à ce moment là
qu'on va arriver à recréer la démocratie
au sein de l'europe parce que le
problème se retrouve uniquement
démultiplier restée maga forcément pour
devant destine à bien d'autres jours a
dit les traiter c'est bien mais il faut
quand même faire attention ne vous
rendez compte
il a une qui dix ans je découvre le
peuple c'est une populiste et l'autre
qui livrent découvre la souveraineté
c'est un souverainisme macro et eva
damas garçons dé sauver nos populations
elle va écouter bravo pour cet exercice
de synthèse périco légasse le dernier
bout à nos internautes à nicole qui nous
dit les européens ont certainement en
tête autre chose qu'une armée et une
europe donneuse de leçons et christophe
qui nous dit avec ironie moi je veux
bien la protection sociale française
le taux d'emploi de l'allemagne et le
régime fiscal du luxembourg bravo belle
conclusion
c'est un bref concert là il veut le
veilleur à l'epr et l'argent du beurre
parlons un sujet qui n'a rien à voir
laurent wauquiez le président des
républicains participé hier à une
journée de débats organisés par sens
commun ce mouvement qui à l'intérieur
deux des républicains soutient les idées
et les convictions de la manif pour tous
il a parlé de la procréation
médicalement assistée et il a considéré
que c'était une forme d'eugénisme globo
est évidemment très fort voici les
arguments développés par laurent
wauquiez pour l'utiliser et s'étendre
linge mènera nécessairement à la
marchandisation des galets à l'image de
ce site internet danoise cryos que vous
devriez aller voir
[Musique]
on vous pouvez sélectionner si vous
voulez qu'il y ait la peau blanche où
vas tu
si vous voulez que ses yeux soit plus
ouvert si vous voulez que ses cheveux
soir ou à l'arrivée le panier d'achat
aura juste remplacer le caddie la zone
parano mais c'est la seule différence
tout ceci a annoncé l'organisme tout
ceci a été fait par un régime c'est le
nazisme
donc il a parlé de génisses mme laurent
wauquiez la ministre de la santé agnès
buzyn à lui a répondu ce matin elle a
dit sur son compte twitter c'est faux et
archi faux
regardez aujourd'hui aucune politique
publique en france
et heureusement n'induit de l'eugénisme
l'eugénisme je le rappelle c'est le fait
de vouloir faire une sélection génétique
pour aboutir à des hommes parfaits
c'était effectivement ce que souhaitait
faire les nazis homme parfait entre
guillemets et évidemment aucun acte
médical en france ne peut conduire à
l'eugénisme s'est dévoyé le sens des
mots c'est irresponsable pour un soi
disant responsables politiques et je
voulais faire part de mon indignation
alors nous versons un élément au dossier
nous sommes allés sur ce site internet a
crié aux tanks dans par laurent wauquiez
et ce qui est vrai après vous nous direz
c'est de l'eugénisme ou non c'est que
vous pouvez choisir à la carte
on a expliqué qu'on était français et
on l'a demandé voilà on cherche on
cherche un donneur et on nous dit quelle
race quelle couleur de cheveux
quel est le poids du donneur son origine
ethnique la couleur des yeux
donc c'est vraiment le bébé sur mesure
est ce que c'est une forme d'eugénisme
ça frédéric dabi même si le mot fait
peur
je pense que oui là c'est qu'ils sont là
parce que si oui le site est
particulièrement spectaculaire
on n'a rien inventé c'est normalement on
va faire tous nos internautes oui mais
là ces termes et s'il le faut je dirais
joie de soucis dans ce qu'a dit laurent
wauquiez
le souci c'est que on est quand même
loin du débat sur la pma ou c'est vrai
qu'une majorité de français la
soutiennent sauf effectivement
l'électorat de françois fillon
l'élection présidentielle sur cette
question par rapport au mariage pour
tous les clivages se sont très fortement
atténué deuxième effet c'est plus un
effet collatéral voilà laurent wauquiez
fait d'actualité sur une thématique qui
n'est pas au coeur des préoccupations
des français
il ya une dimension de brouillage de son
discours nous n'attendons pas en tant
que chef d'un des principaux partis
d'opposition
sur les questions dont on vient de
parler l'a précédemment notamment la
mobilisation des filets jaunes le
pouvoir d'achat et la critique frontale
de l'action du président de la
république sait je serais pour un petit
peu décalé mais très décalé par rapport
au discours et des français et à la
période sur le mot lui-même match
olivier babeau bois quand j'ai entendu
cette expression me suis dit non c'est
trop fort effectivement année ce butin
disait le g10 et la volonté d'avoir
l'homme parfait et on n en est pas là
sauf qu effectivement on se dit si des
couples de lesbiennes veulent avoir un
donneur de sperme et que l on recourt à
un site comme celui là bas on est quand
même dans une forme d'eugénisme ou pas à
votre avis les oui mais je crois que
c'est très difficilement contestable le
génie c'est passera réellement l'homme
parfait six ans et l'homme sélectionner
ses sélectionnés certaines choses là on
part on parle du nazisme et les
spartiates le faisait quand il éliminer
les bébés qui ne s'estimait pas bon et
puis on le fait depuis très très
longtemps parce que on demande aux
maires quand on leur dit votre enfant a
une chance d'être atteint 2
de trisomie 21 est ce que voulait la
supprimer dans 99% des cas elle fait
donc le génie je suis désolé il existe
déjà
le vrai problème à l'occasion du débat
sur la pma c'est que finalement on se
rend compte que les techniques de
sélection on va les avoir
elles vont être de plus en plus forte et
récemment alors il est peut-être une
case qui va s'ajouter mais c'est le qi
c'est à dire vous allez pouvoir choisir
des parents qui vont avoir un certain qu
on sait que qu en partie héréditaire et
puis vous allez pouvoir
de plus en plus sélectionnés chez vos
enfants ce genre de caractéristiques on
est bien loin de la taille et de la
couleur des yeux
il ya beaucoup de caractéristiques et la
question c'est qu'aujourd'hui évidemment
on pourra mettre toutes les barrières
réglementaires qu'on veut c'est que ça
va être très facile de faire ça ailleurs
d'aller dans des endroits avec beaucoup
moins de scrupules
en chine par exemple ils ont très peu de
scrupules vis-à-vis de ça on va pouvoir
sélectionner donc la capacité
scientifique on va l'avoir
le fait qu'on va pouvoir le faire et que
des gens vont le faire ça c'est
probablement ce qui arrive on est sur le
toboggan et génique à toute vitesse
il faudrait qu on ouvre les yeux qu'on
arrête de pousser des cris d'orfraie
comme si ce n'était pas vrai c'est la
réalité il est pro le montant qu'on ait
un débat réel sur la question parce que
c'est quelque chose qui nous arrive dans
les mois qui viennent c'est déjà
probablement là et le débat en louvre
ici c'est aussi ça la la mission de
points de vue car l'une valentin votre
opinion sur ce sujet mon opinion c'est
que laurent wauquiez a fait ça le
révoquer a du mal à avoir un projet bien
cadré et donc il court un peu après
l'actualité ils essaient de faire parler
dans les médias donc plus on prend des
mots à forte connotation émotionnelle
que ça marche donc en fait c'est
simplement un épisode de politique
politicienne cette grande commedia
dell'arte politique ou lui parle de
génisses mon pare de lui dans les médias
puis macron s'insurgeant macron et ses
sbires s'insurge pas très intéressant en
fait alors ce qui est intéressant
peut-être c'est si on prend un peu si on
fait un pas en arrière et qu'on
réfléchisse aux débats de fond il ya
deux choses à dire premièrement que
génisses ppm a fondamentalement sont
quand même deux sujets différents et qu'
il ya des sujets à évoquer au sujet de
la pma des pma son père surtout que
que laurent wauquiez on a été bien
inspiré de développer un peu plus
effectivement ensuite il ya ce sujet de
l'eugénisme et c'est un sujet qui est
discutée par plein de grands
intellectuels
malheureusement on a l'impression que
les hommes politiques les responsables
politiques n'entendent pas ces
intellectuels mais notamment il ya je
crois c'est xavier il s'appelle ce vous
aviez klein que je crois qu'ils
parlaient de la différence entre
l'innovation et le progrès il disait le
mot progrès a disparu en fait du
vocabulaire intellectuelle et maintenant
on ne parle que d'innovation or c'est
pas la même chose puisque le progrès
c'est une aspiration à un monde meilleur
on définit là on veut aller on se donne
les moyens d'y aller alors que
l'innovation c'est ondes et à ce moment
présent et puis on essaie de s'en
échapper et finalement sans savoir où on
va donc il ya une façon peut-être plus
intelligente plus sereine plus un peu
comme macro l'avait fait aux bernardins
de dire qu' il faut de la philosophie et
qu'on doit il faut réfléchir que les
offices mans à cette espèce de deux
d'accélération scientifique et de
l'innovation technologique qui nous
conduit en seo le point de vue dollars
qui nous dit je connais très bien ce
sujet dans ma famille il y a deux
enfants issus de la pma là maman a
vraiment choisi ses enfants en fonction
de l'homme tandis qu'en t-mac estime que
laurent wauquiez a raison sur le fond
mais qu'il n'aurait pas dû dire
eugénisme périco légasse votre point de
vue laurent wauquiez a l'habitude de
faire des déclarations dans des milieux
confinés où ils pensent que ne l'entend
pas il est en terrain conquis avec avec
sens commun voilà ils pouvaient pas se
tromper
là où il faut comprendre le mécanisme de
sa pensée et c'est vrai et je voyais à
l'instant le communiqué de benjamin
griveaux qu'élise ont tout le monde
garde le cap à la république en marche
on se bat avec quelqu'un qu'on fait on
garde le cap à savoir on se tiendra
strictement à la pma mais laurent
wauquiez des donneurs de sperme
il a rappelé quand il ya eu le pack sans
nous a dit il n'y aura pas le mariage
pour tous je me souviens d'hommes
politiques qui parlent et solennellement
devant les français ignorent quand on a
fait le paillage pour tous je me
souviens président il n'y aura pas de
pma la classe politique mais au parti
socialiste
et quand on fait la pma on le dit il n'y
aura pas de gestation pour autrui très
jeune est d'ailleurs est-ce par autrui
de mère porteuse là c'est pas seulement
qu'on va les génisses qui est
aujourd'hui un acte mais on est en train
de faire de préparer bientôt il y aura
même plus besoin d'eux il y aura des
dégâts m et des embryons tout près qu'on
ira chercher dans des commerces
ça va se faire ça existe déjà donc c'est
pas le génie ce moto course et
l'eugénisme mercantine pas ce qu'on
trouvera un moyen de commercialiser
cette génisse pour faire du profit et on
choisira ensuite qui on veut et comme on
veut c'est une remise en cause de
l'humanité
de façon absolument tragique pour
satisfaire une minorité à laquelle je
reconnais le droit effectivement d'avoir
envie d'être parents mais c'est toujours
pour satisfaire immunité qu'on remet en
cause un ordre de l'humanité un ordre
mondial qu'il faut être pensés avec des
lois de bioéthique beaucoup plus
subtilement est beaucoup plus
délicatement que d'aller comme ça le
progrès cette franchir à chaque fois un
stade on est au pacs on est aux portes
de la gpa mais c'est le sens du progrès
c'est le sens de l'histoire non ça peut
être aussi une régression barbade et de
l'innovation
l'innovation est en marche
on sait que le sujet est compliqué pour
le grade puisqu'il a décidé de remettre
à l'année prochaine le monachisme le
calonnois la gpa est interdite en france
elle se fait aux états unis oui mais là
mais qu'est ce que vous voulez faire
contre ça il ya eu le mois dernier
acerbes animateurs qui a fait beaucoup
de médias pour exporter les vieilles
chaussettes famille une famille normale
voilà c'est vrai que là aussi ont une
fois de plus la france n'est pas
l'ofag à la gpa sais je choisis le
profil de mon enfant je veux tel
quotient je veux qu'ils la blanquette de
veau qui lisent le figaro qui fasse de
la course à pied et que voilà
et qu'elle apprécie périco légasse
certainement pas forcément une qualité
qui ont été faits à l'étranger
un dernier commentaire de nicolas qui
dit n'en déplaise à laurent wauquiez a
raison car quand on peut choisir son
futur enfant
selon des critères et bien on le fait il
nous reste quelques minutes pour parler
d'un sujet plus léger
airbnb vous savez ce ce site internet
qui propose à la location des logements
privés c'est un succès considérable
avait bien débuté à 10 ans rien qu'au
troisième trimestre 2010 8
il ya eu 400 millions de personnes qui
ont utilisé les services de ce site il
paraît en tout cas c'est les chiffres
d'airbnb que 20 1 français sur 5 et
clients delà de la plate forme alors les
responsables politiques en tout cas
certains d'entre eux ont mis en place un
certain nombre de mesures pour contrer
herbiers une vie c'est le cas des
députés qui ont voté en fin de semaine
dernière dans le cadre du budget 2010
neuf de nouvelles sanctions contre les
propriétaires qui louent par airbnb mais
qui ne satisfont pas les nouvelles taxes
il ya une taxe de séjour il ya aussi une
surtaxe de 15% en ile de france il ya un
maximum de 120 nuits par an l'objectif
il est clair c'est de ne pas laisser à
bienne be trop se développer c'est aussi
celui de ian brossât qui est le
l'adjoint au logement dal hidalgo
l'adjoint communiste au logement et qui
sont expliquées d'ailleurs très
ouvertement en septembre dernier dans
l'hyper centre de paris aujourd'hui un
logement sur quatre ne sert plus à loger
des parisiens c'est à dire que nous
avons des logements qui se sont
transformés en machines à cash à
destination des touristes et tout cela
d'ailleurs des conséquences en cascade
parce que non seulement les habitants
sont remplacés par des touristes mais
les commerces de bouche sont remplacées
par des commerces de fringues et c'est
donc l'identité du quartier qui finit
par être complètement transformée sous
l'effet de ces locations touristiques
sauf frédéric dabi que les français ils
adorent airbnb la preuve c'est qu'ils en
auraient un sur cinq il utilise donc oui
c'est c'est vrai qu'on est sur 7
sur cette tension là airbnb ç'a permis
une démocratisation du tourisme encore
plus fort mais effectivement il ya une
concurrence déloyale vis-à-vis du
secteur de l'hôtellerie puisque on ne la
quitte pas en théorie de taxe de séjour
et c'est vrai mais je suis parisien qui
adore paris il ya quelques rues de paris
non pas dans l'hyper centre
mais par exemple du côté de la tour
eiffel j'en ai une ou deux recettes où
on a l'impression qu'il n'ya plus de
logement il n'y a que des appartements
dits donc de ce point de vue une fois
cela n'a pas seulement été fait à paris
mais dans beaucoup de villes européennes
quelle que soit l'orientation politique
de la ville il y a peut être besoin de
légiférer ce qui n'enlève rien à
l'adhésion des français aux concepts
gagné en tant que joueur ou en tant que
l'utilisateur car une vingt ans la
raison de vouloir contraindre airbnb
écoutez il ya un problème qui a été
constaté par à peu près toutes les
grandes métropoles effectivement de
transformation des grandes métropoles en
ville musée et de destruction petit à
petit david quartiers où il ya plus
d'habitants permanents
les appartements sont loués exactement
maintenant la politique qui est menée
par les communistes de la mairie de
paris ou politiques extrêmes comme une
liste celle d'hier où c'est vraiment
l'interdiction des sanctions d'un
montant absolument incroyable et c'est
passé pas dire nous on est quand même
dans une démocratie où la propriété
privée et le fait de pouvoir utiliser
son bien comme on le veut et fait partie
des piliers quand même de notre
république
je comprends qu'un communiste l'oubli et
moi je me rappelle et je priais
peut-être d'autres façons de lutter ou
de limiter à bienne be c'est à dire de
faire en sorte par des taxes est
approprié ou d en allégeant la taxation
qui des taxes qui pèsent sur les hôtels
de mettre un peu les hôtels etc etc
loueur là à égalité un peu comme hubert
et les taxis bon après deuxième petite
remarque
j'aimerais qu'ils aient autant de
violence on veut dire des déterminations
une véhémence de détermination pour
lutter contre d'autres types
d'infractions pénales notamment dans les
quartiers
port de la burqa des larmes quand jedir
moi j'aime bien 12500 euros damende pour
le port de la burqa je trouvais ça très
bien franchement il faut choisir ses
combats
olivier babeau oui soit qu'il faut il
faut d'abord saluer l'extraordinaire
avantage de ce système
yardi enum il y en a d'autres c'est
souvent ce que mme hubert on parle que
du leader maintenant il y en a d'autres
c'est l'économie du partage c'est le
fait que pour beaucoup de gens c'est
objectivement une façon de d'arrondir
les fins de mois tout à fait réelle dans
votre ça vous permet aussi de garder un
appartement d'avoir les moyens de garder
un appartement dans paris et en fait de
lutter contre la gentryfication parce
que sinon vous pourriez aussi avoir que
des gens riches qui n'ont pas du tout
besoin de louer et ce serait absolument
pas absolument pas différent finalement
la faune pour appeler ça la venise à
sion du des centre-villes parce que s'il
ya bien une ville qui est comme ça c'est
venise il ya quasiment plus de vénitiens
il ya plus que des hôtels il ya plus que
des touristes sa pré existants airbnb
vers ce phénomène là il existait bien
avant et donc finalement il ya beaucoup
de gens pour qui ça correspond à
vraiment quelque chose on a eu une
création de trafic on a aussi une
création de touristes qui rapporte
beaucoup d'argent parce que ce qu'on dit
pas c'est que les gens qui viennent
grâce à bienne be tous ces gens qui
viennent ils viennent dépenser et on est
les premiers à être content d'avoir
cette cette manne financière
je crois qu'effectivement on devrait
avoir une réponse plus intelligente en
termes d'égalité vis-à-vis des hôtels
qui ont des contraintes totalement
délirante d'accessibilité la taxe de
séjour bon bah oui ça c'est tout à fait
vrai d'ailleurs maintenant je crois
qu'elle est prélevé maintenant aussi les
gens vont pouvoir payer directement en
sorte qu'à leurs revenus via ce genre de
plateforme va être rapportées au fisc
donc ils vont devoir le déclarer donc
recettes fiscales je crois que c'est pas
la peine de rajouter des sanctions et
des taxes et de la collectivisation à ce
qui pourrait être tout à fait réguler de
façon de façon pour hier raisonnement
des outils périco légasse on va on va se
tourner vers nos internautes on vous
pose la question sur twitter selon-vous
l'assemblée nationale at elle raison de
renforcer les sanctions contre les
locations airbnb vous répondez oui à 63%
pour ce qui n'est pas un sondage on ne
répète à nouveau
et puis quelques quelques commentaires
nicole nous dit comme d'habitude on s'en
prend à la bnb pour avoir davantage de
taxes qui échappait au gouvernement
et assez nous dit la cupidité des
problèmes peut-être une finalité en
matière de politique de logement paix
colegas ce que vous êtes adeptes
d'airbnb non je suis pas adepte et je
suis très inquiet parce que c'est pas
libéral le libéralisme ce serait qu' une
loyauté commercial et fiscal vis-à-vis
d'un secteur est essentielle à
l'économie française
président la république est le premier à
dignac a traversé la rue et
l'hôtellerie-restauration a besoin de
métier cette concurrence là je ne suis
pas sûr qu'elle rapporte autant
d'économie nationale évidemment ces gens
consomment mais c'est souvent des gens
qui ont des petits réunit des moyens
revenus et qui consomme très très
chichement on n'a jamais vu pour
l'instant d'essort économique ou de
création d'emplois voilà ensuite ça
ouvre la porte à une forme de gestion et
de fraude de contournement des lois dont
on a aujourd'hui quelques cas extrêmes
inquiétant où ça échappe totalement au
contrôle de l'état
on a déjà passé de fonctionnaires pour
contrôler les impôts de nos propres de
nos propres dirigeants
je fais allusion à rien mais évidemment
on aura pas qu'on n'aura pas plus de
fonctionnaires pour surveiller foyer par
foyer cette mère que mercantilisation
non pas du ventre là pour apprendre à
sauter d'un coq à l'âne mais voilà de ce
patrimoine immobilier parisien qui est
vaste il ya des auteurs qui sont en
difficulté il ya des hôtels qui sont en
train de fermer qui créent des emplois
qui sont eux qui paient et qui payent
des taxes donc la décevoir en libéral
effectivement il faut abandonner que
airbnb d'accord mais ils payent le prix
est en tout cas vis-à-vis des kits et
des autres activités hôtelières il faut
absolument être dans une politique de
justice qui n'est pas le cas la plupart
des activités à bienne be sont
interdites
c'est réservé aux gens qui sont
propriétaires qui ne peuvent louer leur
propre appartement que 10 semaines par
an quant aux autres à paris en tout cas
c'est interdit sauf si vous achetez un
autre local commercial politique
commerciale que vous transformez en
local d'habitation
il ya plus de contrôles paca une
trentaine d'agents n'a vu de paris
d'ailleurs quand on voit le montant des
amendes depuis le début de l'année ça ça
la peur du gendarme commence à être
absolument merci beaucoup à tous les cas
elle doit participer à cette émission
qui s'achève merci à vous tous chers
internautes
et à demain pour un nouveau rendez-vous
de point de vue bonne soirée
[Musique]